The first thing we're gonna talk about is getting a board that's right for you.
We want you to have a board that's great to learn on,...
...but also good enough for you to surf well on when you improve.
The best board for this is a "fish."
Alrighty now, basically a "fish" is a mix between a longboard and a shortboard.
These boards are a little bit thicker and thus more buoyant,...
...meaning they make you float better.
Now, the reason we're steering away from the shortboards for now...
...is because they're a little bit thin,...
...and it's gonna be hard to paddle and hard to catch waves.
The reason we're staying away from the longboards is although they're easy to catch waves on,...
...they're hard to paddle and negotiate the waves with.
So, we got you something in the middle, the "fish."